vuelven a ocupar los estrechos canales
del sena en este barco parisino muchos
turistas extranjeros llegan emocionados
una vez más por descubrir la capital
francesa y sus monumentos
desde que era pequeña soñaba con venir a
parir realmente es un placer oír del mal
tiempo de casi sacar a los niños del
reino unido hemos estado atrapados allí
durante los últimos 18 meses
después de un largo periodo de ausencia
los nuevos clientes son una buena señal
para este capitán
hay más que en verano si vienen de nuevo
desde octubre no es una locura pero
cazar
ya sea en la tarde al pie de la torre
field o frente a estos grandes almacenes
los turistas están ahí pero muchos como
los habituales visitantes de origen
asiático se han quedado fuera en parís
durante el año pasado los extranjeros
representaron sólo el 25 por ciento del
turismo frente al 50 por ciento de 2019
la mayoría de estos vacacionistas
foráneos proceden de europa de lugares
como alemania bélgica o italia la
tendencia se ha extendido a lo largo
toda la costa azul en este hotel de
antibes las habitaciones podrían estar
llenas pero la propietaria tiene que
arreglárselas con algunas ausencias
notables y naut el clip entre los
clientes que no volvieron están los
rusos los sudamericanos tampoco la
pequeña tendencia que vimos en agosto
fue la de la clientela estadounidense
pero se desvaneció de nuevo en
septiembre
de este año francia espera recibir 50
millones de turistas extranjeros una
cifra todavía muy lejos del récord de 90
millones de visitantes de 2019